ha ha ha bienvenue où cette nouvelle
vidéo et voilà aujourd'hui donc on est
en direct en roulant sur tweets et c'est
la première fois de ma vie que je vais
faire un stream avec la fibre donc je
suis tout excité je peux être une
meilleure qualité vidéo et je pense que
le pouvoir un peu tout ouvrir en même
temps rien ne va me ghetto va être
fantastique on est complètement au
dessus et donc pour fêter ça on va faire
des parties avec les spectateurs un jeu
très content à la fibre on fait toujours
très très très heureux là je serai très
heureux donc ça va être le stream du
bonheur la bonne humeur on est partout
rien ne rame
c'est fantastique donc je vais accepter
vos défis si vous m'en proposer si vous
proposez de pâtes des fibres gérer
défier des gens moi même je me
débrouillerai et je défoncerait d'autres
personnes donc ce que tu as le mode et
me de proposer des parties allez-y on
est bon on est bon les mecs je courais
partout rien ne va me gay cette
fantastique je suis complètement
conceptuellement au dessus avec la fibre
enfin je crois être bon au dessus de
tout la ouais ça marche à tout qui
s'ouvre ja happ ça ne rame pas du tout
c'est fantastique je peux même regardez
les pubs je vais vous regardez les pubs
de la chaîne twitch ça marche
ces riders tu veux on fera un stream je
regarde des pubs ça va être très très
intéressant tient kingda d'illéla
canalplay you you can't you just the way
you just foot chalet du me fait très
attention avec l'anglais c'est très
important les enfants l'anglais par les
anglais c'est très important ça vous
faire il faut parler anglais les jeunes
allaient souhaite encore à l'école s et
c'est très important d'apprendre des
onglets à avoir des bonnes notes en
anglais c'est très très bien ça peut
vous servir et bien plus calmes
intéressant beaucoup de contenu en
anglais sur internet des chansons des
musiques les séries télé aussi un si
vous regardez les séries en anglais sous
titré anglais c'est quand même mieux
plus drôle
je pense à des séries série notamment
humoristique mais surtout c'est vrai
pour tous les tissus de toutes les
séries 1 quand tu commences à regarder
en anglais tu ne peux plus regarder en
vf les services est plus possible donc
j'attends le dfid qui le délai dit qu'il
dédie sortie en algérie là j'avoue
canaris pays où coiffe un fou mais c'est
une propose propose pas de partie on est
mal
non mais ça va arriver ki moon a dit on
le jeu le sang chaud il doit se demander
ce qu'on dit à propos de lui d'ailleurs
bon je vous laisse un peu arrivé un jeu
souffle est-ce qu'on joue à quatre où
est-ce qu'on joue g4 d'ailleurs c'est un
peu la question
personne ne veut personne ne veut me
défier tout le monde a peur ou pas
d'ailleurs
peut-être oui oui pourquoi je voudrais
contre cet idiot ce serait perdre dix
minutes de ma vie était du coup les mecs
ne veulent pas perdre leur temps quoi
possible en soit hier assez intelligent
de leur part ce serait assez intelligent
de leur part là alors que se passe-t-il
personne ne joue pas avec modestie c'est
comme ça que personne ne me et que
personne ne me défie je faire un bullet
enfin si vous ne deviez pas à force
c'est moi qui vais vous dit fier on
combien la cadence pour pour les game
bon comme tu venais pas plus de cinq
minutes parce qu'après c'est long et
c'est heureux élus comme on n'est pas
des relou on va faire vite n'importe
quoi est ce le bullet bullet 3 + 3 à 3
030 5 0 5 0 mais plus à présent dans sa
france franchement ça vient ça vient ça
devient je suis en convenir tout de
suite atteignant ninja qui me propose de
jouer j'accepte ce défi
donc nous jouons contre un ninja ok ils
jouent des 4 j'ai très envie de jouer si
ça on va essayer de faire une grande
bouche d'accord c'est tendu tous font
manger c'est très intéressant
nous prenons de l'espace à l'endroit
ninja 30 360
si si ils représentent 30 360 tonton
sept ans qu'elle est froide j'ai quatre
langues et il se défend qui a eu 7 puis
on le pion est en prise alors on veut se
venger sur des quatre ninjas s'en prend
à un autre pion moi je pense qu'il va
falloir le largue espion on va faire des
il aura fait le taf il aura fait le taff
le pion le pion g5 comprend on reprend
des comme ça maintenant pourra jouer le
g4 un peu comme une attaque spike bout
attaque ce pas un peu dans la merde pour
le moment mais ça va on survit pas trop
mal ok on va faire j'ai quatre
maintenant le fou est venu à la
rescousse
le faut venir à la rescousse on va
essayer de se battre à fond peut-être
mettra le pion h5 pour soutenir
on va soutenir on va attaquer le fou on
va réattaquer le fou avec le foin f5 ou
pas que doit-on faire bien une
farfouille 6 en fait vous avez fait kf4
ont fait dame 17 et on reprendra du pion
pour un peu solidifier tout ça s'en va
solidifier le centre ce que j'ai pas
très envie de me retrouver qu'un pion
trop faible en d5 vrai on reprend du
pillon on consolide sur blanc et on fera
du cavalier a5a et ses quatre plus tard
faut toujours regarder des trucs aussi
je recueille 35 des quatre arrêts mais
qui avec des fourchettes
ça peut être pas mal ça peut être pas
mal à voir donc et yves roques
bon on continue dans l'esprit à fond un
grand roque c'est dans l'esprit mais ok
pour regarder comme les cas il prend et
d4 vraiment j'ai pas envie de calculer
parce que j'ai la flemme naiman un jour
ou l'autre il faudra ne plus avoir la
flemme
gk vallée b 4 qui peut être pas mal il
ya plusieurs trucs qui peuvent être
jouable
une flemme de calculer c'est horrible il
n'y a rien de pire quand tu aux échecs
quand t'as pas envie de calculer afin
que je me décide pour un truc quand même
aux fauves au bout d'un moment je le
disais pour le truc le plus bizarre
cavaliers avec cinq pour le seul truc
que j'ai pas calculer en fait mais
qu'elle détient et prend des cinq qui
marche je sais pas ok il va attaquer là
bas pas mal joué encore à faire qui est
b4 on va s'en prendre aux fous qui on va
prendre là et on va faire des quatre
mais peut-être qu'il prend des cinq qui
est très fort d'ailleurs ici prise prise
prise en d5
ok il n'a pas joué ça c'était peut-être
très fort comme apprendre en h4
ça reste un peu chaud hein qu'est prison
à reprendre du pillon stylisé de base ou
g5 bon ok pas grave on va mettre le kf5
on va reprendre en des 800 peut-être
prendre du roi léon va se barrer en un
autre qualité de moins me bon d'une
pollution tranquille quoi traîne qui l'a
renvoyé les pions bouble pions c'est
peut-être pas le plus intelligent ça
mais bon on va le faire tomber on va le
faire tomber
ça va le faire
allez on monte avec le roi ou pas non je
pense va être pragmatique faut qu'on
joue la pendule ou monte avec le roi
dame 17 et non non non non soyons
pragmatiques nous avons le temps nous
ont le temps allez on joue le temps
qu'ils ont appréhendé quatre soyons
pragmatiques très important le
pragmatisme les enfants regardent faire
flasher s'ils ont attaqué le cavalier je
sens qu'on va on va même mater tu vas
faire un truc mètres la tour un char à
défendre le pion ça va le faire cavaler
h quatre fours g5
on va les enfermer le cavalier est ce
qu'il ya un matt est ce qu'il ya un truc
voile et pragmatisme
ok ninja qui a pas mal joué alors qu'est
ce qu'on en a grenoble allez on va
accepter le défi de grenoble alors
grenoble bombe à grenoble grenoble 2-3
tient de trois poisons empoisonnant
grenoble ces six baies 3 on va
développer
un peu comme naka dans son match contre
car yakine avec le four b2 qui est bien
soutenue par par les pions jamais trop
faire dans cette position là c'est ce
que faire de ce cavalier toujours un peu
des problèmes normal maintenant de 2 on
va faire on va mettre le quai en deux
ans
on va mettre la dame en vidéo on va
pousser g4 boom direct comme ça si prend
pas on va mettre la tour angers 1 1 et
on va tout de suite attaqué sur sur g7
s'avère très empoisonné c'est du poison
ne faisons que du poison
bon on va pousser j'ai bien envie de
reprendre du cavale quoique non merci on
va prendre dû cavaler on va mettre la
tour en géant va attaquer sur le plonger
sa place à massa va être très tranquille
cette histoire-là mètres la tour angers
c'était tout l'idée d'un match 5
on va on va y aller en force
on va voir on va voir comment il
continue ok il prend on reprend de la
tour on aurait aussi pu prendre du plomb
mais là le truc c'est que le four b2 il
a plus trop de vis-à-vis on va revenir
on va venir en g3 avec la tour comme ça
quand on doublera plus tard on pourra
mettre la tourangelle sens renaître le
fourrage 3 on va faire grand roque
j'ai bien envie de faire f 5 comme ça on
va fermer
on me mettra le l'adamant h5 et
peut-être la tour en âge 3 où on va voir
comment mon match mais là on sent que
les pièces noires sont quand même assez
mal placé tout cas on a l'impression
d'un grand roque et est maintenant il va
falloir faire un un tableau de maths
carette l'adamant h5 ça mange pas de
pain et après faire qu'on décide comment
mettre le fouet à les mater à l'ancienne
les tontons peut-être le fou eu deux
d'ailleurs pour mettre la tourache 3 la
dame aurait ensuite avoir le fourrage 5
pour venir couper le roi peut-être avoir
peut-être faire food tour g1 on prépare
un peu et puis après on voit c'est
peut-être du coup le fou plutôt en e2
dans cette structure là c'est maintenant
que le purin f5 parce que sinon h3 bon
il servait éventuellement à protéger
depuis longtemps qu'elles font ans et 8
mais maintenant que le franc à six le
fou va plutôt venir le l'incrusté en h5
je pense pas ce que vous en pensez si
vous avez une idée dans le chat mais ça
me paraît assez logique
l'enfouissement si vous pensez que c'est
complètement con on l'a ya deux écoles à
l'école damage 6 mais bon ça
monopolisera un peu la tour sur la
colonne g où l'école d'un match 4 bon
mes envies de faire d'un match 4 ok
peut-être lui il peut jouer j'ai 5 puis
on prend le pion pranger 6e et au moins
ça lui permet
d'un peut débloquer la situation ok
maintenant ils menacent ce pion là ça
s'est pas mal fait de sa part on va
mettre le fourrage 3 du coup ce qu'on
voulait comme disait on avait un peu la
flexibilité maintenant on veut faire
tour g1 et peut-être damas six possibles
truc c'est que toute façon il n'a pas
trop de jeu 1
il n'a pas trop de jeu de toute façon la
structure de pioncer vraiment mal
goupillé pour lui du coup tout rejet un
refus qui peut jamais parce qu'on va le
choper avec d'un match 8 et là
maintenant menace damas justice
éventuellement et maintenant s'il fait
j'ai 5 ans + hilal cavaliers 17 dans le
viseur et là je vais même pas lui faire
damage suite parce que roy e set et si
je prends g7 il prend à schwyz
donc je n'ai pas le temps mais je vais
faire damage 7 plus fort parce que sur
oise 7 et à tour g7 je gagnais à dan est
ici fait rien les atours g7 et je gagne
la dame aussi et je mate et là il peut
plus défendre son tour g7 cette fois ci
d'ailleurs au pire je pourrais avoir
même un plan com cavalière trois
cavaliers h quatre cavaliers g6 bon on
n'aura pas besoin ok maintenant il fait
ça très bien joué et donc maintenant il
faut conclure alors la grosse faute se
réfère dame premier de ses trois
premiers c'est ce qui aurait pu la prise
en passant donc on va prendre en passant
maintenant et du coup vous voyez le
fourrage crois qu'il va finir la partie
après ce qui doit prendre
on va reprendre ok mais si tu couvres
comme ça tonton lecavalier est en prise
mais en fait de toute façon il aurait
perdu le cavaliere d'une manière x ou y
ok il va venir là on va échanger ma
maman à les échanges on échange on est
revenus
non non non pourquoi pas tout rassurant
avait peut-être des trucs avec tours age
iii qui était possible aussi est-ce
qu'ils avaient ahmad possible avec damas
tourage 3 words faire tourache 3 mais
peut-être dame bouge oui c'était
possible aux siens maintenant on va
ramener le cavalier d'ailleurs à noter
on peut même tête claquée en cinq ans va
prendre et fils du coup et on va tout
ouvrir la tour des huit qui s'offrent à
nous on va la prendre
si tu me donnes je te prends donnez
donnez donnez moi
attention ne pas faire du tour f1 tour
f3 hop le petit échec qui va bien hop
le deuxième petit échec qui va bien hop
le petit troisième échec qui va bien et
comme ça on va pouvoir mater avec le
pion ok donc juste pour dire oui hélas à
ce moment là à la place aux entourages 3
était aussi jouable mais le truc c'est
que je voyais pas tableau de maths dans
ce genre d'idée genre dams est vrai mais
je vais faire d'un match c'est trois là
et et food avec l'idée de faire flasher
cinq monts peut-être le roi ce bar mais
du coup j'aurais pu faire damage 7,3 et
vii da match st croix g8 est fou et deux
avec l'idée de faire d'un match 8 x 2 5
fois sa mode samaté peut-être plus
rapidement mais bon comme j'ai fait dans
la partie avec avec flash 3 et et tour
ici ça marche aussi très bien mais oui
effectivement c'était peut-être même
plus fort de faire tout rage 3 bien vu
le chat et mais bon les deux les deux
les deux fins je leur parlais que la
manière dont j'ai joué je pense pas que
ça ait remis en cause le fait que la
taxe soit fortin donc maintenant je vais
me refaire des défis alors on a des
défis allez on va prendre sept chars
ok ou 4 donc ça arrive à se prendre un
des cinq poison tout est poison et tout
est empoisonnée maintenant d'appliquer
on a le livre d'axel smith on n'en peut
plus qu'en mai du poison partout et le
meilleur maire d'hendaye se suffisent
donc là bon ce qu'on va faire on va
faire on va faire ses 6 on va essayer de
on va essayer de faire service volée
haye ne veut pas tiens tiens prends le
jeu jamais je ne touchera ton clan des 5
je suis un dragon de komodo une morsure
me suffira pas d'amuser cisma tout à
l'heure à cause de deux rois j'ai 8 ans
je pense que roy revenu avec damas cinq
fois je sens que ça devait marcher dans
pas mal de matches possible d'en bas ok
maintenant prend goût d'un moment s'il
payne pas sous les 10 face sept chats ne
veut pas apprendre le pion il ne prend
pas pu enfin nous y avait but il devait
y avoir beaucoup dans la partie
précédente de tableaux de maths mais
j'ai pu rater des trucs ce qui est
difficile parfois c'est quand on a une
idée que ça gagne c'est difficile de
voir d'autres idées en fait ça peut être
quelque chose qui pas forcément évident
auquel on va prendre en f3 ci prend
dessin comprend des 1 il reprend des ans
on prend des cinq on aura pu non plus
ses bonnes structures de pions et s'y
prend à f3 on prend des 4 donc ça c'est
très bien pour nous parce que
bah on a gagné un pion dans la sphère
donc on a plus en plus et on a
excellente structure de pions donc on va
même pas à les changer de pièce on
pourrait arriver à manger aussi ce qu'on
va essayer de le jouer contre le pion
isolé donc on va jouer finale puis en
plus on hamm est aussi sans avoir
structure car au calme face à psion
isolé des quatre futures car aucun de
leurs ce sera le 1 des sujets des master
class de décembre je suis laïc et master
class de naissance
mais on va le bouger bouger dans pièce
tranquillement calé 17 et b6 camp rock
food est ici sans attaquer le pion des 4
on l'a tranquillement monter la pression
sur le pion d'écart à tous avec notre
pion de plus je me faire avec g6 fou g7
on va se laisser cloud et en espérant
que ce soit pas trop grave c'est un peu
coin le seul et c'est fou j'ai 5 fu g7
cavale yeux car est mais bon je pense
que ça tient je pense que ça tient
tranquille où une fois je sais tu vas
bien placé comme ça en vrac les dessins
qu'il en ira tape espion petit à petit
juste cette variante qui a aidé cinq
semaines est calculé et maintenant ce
que je veux c'est peut-être cavaliers
quatre fous des huit qui prend f2
maintenant que j'ai enlevé le fou ok il
enlève son fou aussi du coup ça marche
de plus les deux bouts donc on a un peu
joué avec le feu mais mon souci ça qui
rend ces partis marrante allez on va on
va rentrer là dedans
pas forcément une super idée mais bon
donc oui j'ai ici c'est un peu con con
n'eo ket intérêts que c'est qu'il a
l'air tellement les pièces sont assez
bien placé je suis sûr qu'il ya quelque
chose pour nous qui va qui va être bon
il va prendre en main de façon endémique
pardon on va prendre f2 on attaquera la
tour il bougera la tournant il ne prend
pas on va du coup on fait tour 17
mais bon il y avait des ventes ont gagné
2,3 puis ans j'imagine je pense qu'on
récupère encore on récupère encore un ou
deux pions donc on se retrouve avec deux
trois pions pour la qualité ça suffisait
largement
et maintenant on veut faire cavalier b6
h6 avoir poussé le fou on mettra la tour
en des 8 et on va essayer d'aller taper
le pion on mettra peut-être domaines qui
ont eu cette f5 pour venir bien macérer
lothion
non on va être pas mal on est pas mal ce
que c'est pas dangereux de faire une
grotte avec ce contre la paire de fous
non pas du tout surtout qui a pu les
dames sur l'échiquier donc donc ya pas
de problème à un moment où j'ai fait
grand roi qui a plus de dames 1 donc
qu'est-ce qui peut vraiment m'arriver
comment je peux vraiment faire attaquer
je vois pas du tout c'est toutes les
structures car au 15e tour on aime bien
faire grand roque ce que je fais des
master classes riches et des master
classes donc ok f3 on va chasser on
marche assez
on va coller notre tour en des huit
salles à des problèmes de connexion ils
vont il sera pas déçu la partie était
déjà mal embarqué allez on va jouer
contre qu'adobe un joueur catalan allez
on va refaire notre trois poisons ça
allait pas mal marché
on commence par trois on voit ce qui se
passe lorsque nous fait qu adobe caddoc
un non c'est pas n'importe quel cas
d'orgue la conjointe on joue alors je
vous le numéro un c'est une mini futur
le titre
pas si facile que ça de changer du coup
la partie dans ces rencontres est de 40
s'ouvrait faut qu'ils jouent qu'à des
gains à l'eca d'orgue batwa la
difficulté pour qu'à la glace est
vraiment de jouer le premier coup il a
fessé 5 mm pas vu je fais j'ai pas eu le
son du coup bon bah on va fermer trois
écouter on va rester dans le poison
mettre le fou en b2
j'ai bien envie de jouer ça comme ça
j'ai bien juste avec fougue de et g4
pressé de faire g5 rapidement fkt carré
des f3 jeu pas très heureux du fonds ou
deux peut-être été mieux en g2 mais ok
on va tenter
on va vers du maître le plus rangée 5
cela n'arrange pas de pain et on va
jouer f4 comme ça on va vraiment bien
taper sur sa diagonale
je pense pas que ce soit très bon de
jouer comme ça mais bon on va voir
comment les adversaires réagissent donc
on va faire f 4 vraiment il n'y a pas de
pas de souci s'il fait à chis on a le
temps de faire des trois pour chasser le
cavalier
messi fait rock on est très heureux mais
fou de fo 2 c'était peut-être un peu con
con comme coup on va voir ce qui fait
que va faire qu'à dogues peut peut-être
c'est de rester avec son cavalier vers
f5 mais faut quand même qu'ils règlent
le problème du pion du pion g7 ne serait
que le fou et bien et bien aidé quoi
donc il fait f6 pas idiot on va faire
des trois on va chasser 60 pour appâter
le tolérer ce cavalier très longtemps il
recule on va faire h4 allez-vous vous
c'est une info je pense qu'il reviendra
f5 avec son cavalier
non donc on va développer sa la sueur
qui arrive 5ème s'en remettra le cahier
en f1 tout en contrôle mais je n'aime
pas trop cette ouverture pour le moment
trois poisons a manqué de poids sans
quoi clairement manqué où il développe
pas facile développer la dame en fait
pour nous je connais m lecavalier vert
est fin prêt si on respire pas le
bonheur mettre la dame en d2 on va
rockets bon il ya le centre après
millions est ce si grave
on pourrait la perdre on pourrait la
perdre
allez on va voir ce que ça donne mais là
c'est complètement raté fouet de g5
beaucoup trop optimiste car on est quand
même contents d'une colle un échec et on
warocqué warocqué parce qu'en fait sur
pions prend pions prend puis on prend
prise fou prend je pense un peu trop
optimiste pour les noirs y aura du
cavalier f3 qui suivra et même s'ils
gagnent un pion non ok maintenant je
pense on en profite pour prendre h6 ci
peut pas prendre du cavalier des coûts
et un tout bêtement et va falloir qu'on
fasse un truc original
il réfère kf3 tour g1 et tours j'ai
cette colonne ouverte faut toujours
toujours les principes les plus simples
des échecs
même dans les positions un peu bizarre
un peu étrange feu toujours retourner
sur les basiques colonnes ouverte on
rentre sur la colonne ne peux pas la
contester pascal cavaliere cette emprise
et donc on va essayer d'aller
s'installer là-bas angers7
après avoir si ça marche ou pas mais si
déjà vous vous suivez les basiques dans
vos parties
ce sera très bien la même tour j'ai 6
ans dans les coups possibles avec l'idée
de taper f6 éventuellement cavaler h du
cavaliere 4 plan classique aussi pour
aller taper des pions ok donc ça pas mal
joué je m la tour en v6 plutôt quoique
dont j'essaie de faire tourner g8 donc
ça c'est bien joué de sa part et le
carré long des six assez bien placé
finalement avec les blancs on souffre
toujours de notre ouverture et on
réussit pas et surtout rejet six
cavaliers f5 pénible
sur tours g7 caiap 5 aussi d'ailleurs
donc il réussit bien à couvrir
c'est très bien joué de sa part et on
reste toujours un peu complexe nono
pièce va faire froid b1 j'ai pas trop
d'idées pour le moins on voit bien ce va
être un mauvais coup je protège le pion
à deux est ok mettre le cabanou rage 2
pour lier des tours et menaces
éventuellement kg 4 québec attend comme
je vous disais avoir mis le roi en b1 ça
permet de couvrir des cases mange pas de
pain avec le cadran g4 maintenant on va
s'en prendre aux pions et à celui là là
on a une espèce double attaque
et s'il fait f5 il va ouvrir notre fou
il aurait dû jouer avec des quatrains
plutôt quelque chose je sais pas qui est
prêt même si ce qui va tout raser et
cette fois ci on rentre sur la 7e
et on va tout près move et il a fini par
tomber hockey suivant on va jouer
maintenant contre le gaffeur 1 et on va
on va lui faire cavalier ces trois là on
change un petit peu des six des quatre
il ya aussi ce 4 quai
je vais faire un truc comme une méthode
horizon va jouer comme ça ah non je
voulais faire un rov aie aie aie aie aie
aie aie du coup j'ai eu m la dame en d2
faire grand roque et où on perd 40 temps
et en plus on se prend à f 5 parce qu'on
s'est auto cloud et non mais f5 pas si
grave au final parce que il ouvre un peu
la position il donne des cases on va
reculer on va commencer à taper aussi ce
quart est le cavalier h trois essais de
venir par là ok en arrivant j'ai 5 et là
on est très heureux
malgré le miz clic on a perdu un peu de
temps mais on tape le plus réussi sans
force je pense meilleur coup c'est de
faire cavalier de 4 malgré tout et ça
joue encore ce que normal on devra
plutôt une position comme ça et avec un
ou deux ans de plus à mes cavaliers aux
quatre auraient peut-être pu faire avec
un pdf set mais est ce que je fait
recaler fait quand même qu'est pour lui
si ce bon tous gagnent enfin à tous
gagnent tout donne un avantage niamien
kiev 16 sa période de d'attaquer le fou
une nouvelle fois et surtout g7 je vais
même pas prendre dire est une tour en
fait je pense quoique bon avoir marqué
mais là on prend le fou plus tôt on
prend pas la qualité du coup on prend le
fourrage 6 beaucoup plus fort que la
qualité évidemment
et maintenant on va faire notre petit
notre petit ménage on va échanger les
pièces et ont essayé de tranquillement
gagné
ouais encore cavaliers ou quatre il
serait pas mal joué j'ai peut-être
fouache 4 qui était très fort en fait
pour supprimer le cavalier en jouant sur
le clouage donc on va prendre on va
mettre la dame ans
3 ou n'importe où on va faire j'ai
quatre et on va faire j'ai 5h 4h 5h à
faire j'ai quatre quand même si ça
échange c'est cool on récupère le pion
de 4,9 la position en une pièce de plus
si ça prend pas bon on va jouer j'ai 5 h
4 h 5 et j'ai 6 ans et on va les jouer
pour ce truc là à jouer pour le pion
passé qui est venue de ce côté là on est
là tous rage 6
quand même que je fasse gaffe je suis
pas très concentré là
c'est sûr dangereux ne pas être
concentrés surtout chorale exercèrent
attaque voix 3 mais bon pas l'impression
d'être en grand danger donc l'impression
que ça va mais bon qui sait d'après
c'est un peu ma range avec le fury si
bon il commence à créer des menaces il
est temps de le chasser
la science pas qu'ils puissent créer de
menaces de maths je vois pas de
possibilité de créer des menaces de
maths pour les noirs mais m e pons juste
toujours dangereux les dessins comme ça
nous va menacer mat
voilà qu'est ce qu'on fait j'ai envie de
dire alors pour à gratter ce plan la
barre assez solide qui n'a pas de fous
de cases noires donc il va avoir du mal
à mater sur ces cases là et le cavalier
il tient la casa de donc ça me paraît
difficile de voir un tableau de maths
pour mon adversaire mais bon j'aurais pu
jouer de manière un peu plus un peu plus
prudente mais je vois pas du tout
comment je me fais maths et en fait là
c'est nous qui m'attend allez on
comprend prochain adversaire
on va prendre le duc de normandie boom
g4 bomba g45 j'ai envie de dire si vous
voulez jouer à fond dans l'esprit voulu
prendre quelqu'un qui ne joue pas du
tout dans l'esprit c'est un concept très
intéressant
j'aurai mon cavalier vers les bonnes
cases protéger le pion
très heureux je trais de mon cas et
angers 6
ok bon on va faire h5 maintenant on va
s'en prendre
on va s'en prendre aux fous
tout cas plus trop de casse du coup
c'est obligé de revenir vers f1 est très
content avec notre cavalier en h4 et ça
les empêche pas de faire du cavalier f3
dans de bonnes conditions
bon ben ok mon de chasse on te chasse et
on va te prendre et on va te prendre là
je comprends pas trop l'intérêt dans la
sphère fait faire ses six sur l'apathie
considère que c'est pas c'est pas une
bonne idée pour marjorie 6,6 après je
sais pas on va développer fou g4 leucate
damev 6 et cavaliers et le cavalier qui
tombe à du de normandie le duc de
normandie le duc de normandie qui qui va
devoir abandonner
elle dit qu'elle ou qu'elle ait
normandie c'est hot on va prendre ça
maintenant j'ai une idée marrante on va
prendre ça va pas marcher
je voulais faire d'alger six tours prend
et mater sur la première mais ça n'a pas
marché
j'essaye de faire un truc marrant on va
faire flouer 7 ça n'a pas marché je veux
faire un truc drôle mais ok mais
maintenant dame g6 à mais il part versé
3 avec le roi ça marche pas
ça ne marche pas bon c'est pas faire le
truc drôle pour le moment maintenant est
ce que ça marche ça marche plus du tout
pour être capable de se mettre en
difficulté pour faire marcher le truc du
sacrifice de dames et on n'y arrive pas
alors moi remettre la tour en hdmi
warocqué mois et coûté 1
on va faire pragmatique et ma pièce qui
ont plu sont échangés les dames on va la
faire à la pragmatique on réussit pas à
faire marcher les beaux trucs hockey et
justine cas de plus en fait je sais pas
je mets en galère tout seul et mon la
foulée 6 en plus très bien parce que on
va voir une tour de plus ça devrait le
faire quand même
mais j'aurais bien aimé ouais j'aurais
bien aimé faire marcher un truc là paris
si minces voire un retour à partie suite
alors qu'on fasse gaffe comprendre ici
ça peut menacer vous bafouez s'ils sont
échangées et on va faire tour a chuté
je sais c'est un peu difficile pour moi
de ses positions sur du mal en fait avec
la motivation aux joueurs de position
ces deux cavaliers 3 je suis pas je
laisse du jeu c'est n'importe quoi juste
un problème d'argent avec les positions
gagnantes sur czech comme je n'arrive
juste pas motivant quand une position
gagnante et à la jouer correctement
donc il va faire des cinq des cats ce
sera fini mais bon ça aurait dû être
plus simple
un tour de plus un rêve et 4 ok c'est
pas encore totalement ok manach et touré
pièce de plus
bon je sais pas trop quoi a commenté en
fait je le comprends pas ce qui se passe
voilà je comprends pas pourquoi encore
en train de jouer en fait ce qui est
assez difficile des amis difficile
difficile je sais ma tête vite possible
ok alors il nous reste des défis on va
prend et on va prendre un 3 0
et nous alors on va lui faire des cartes
rails et c'est un peu changé d'ouverture
à chaque fois il nous joue cavalier f6
on va lui faire une trompe ce qui allait
jouer le répertoire normal ok ça c'est
la théorie prise prise le 3 ça fout c4
je ne suis pas sûr d'un v6 est ce que
c'est vraiment bronchait pas on verra on
verra en temps voulu
j'espère cavalia soirée faire dame prend
maintenant veux-tu pas si bien c'est
complètement de la merde ce que j'ai
fait ok ben on va essayer de s'en sortir
numérique sous y
j'aime apprendre
en fait j'ai envie de me faire plein
avec un truc complètement con bon allez
c'est très mauvais je pense non on va
essayer quand même qu'elle ne faire
plaisent avec ce truc là genre ni décès
sur roy prend je veux faire cavalier
saint-croix g8 damas cinq à fond à fond
à fond quoi à avoir on va avoir droit
des huit c'est bien joué donc et je vais
revenir avec le fou à faire ses trois
protégés
on est très mal on a une tour de moins
pour quasi zéro compensation mais on a
deux trois idées auxquelles on a
peut-être l'idée de récupérer la dame
manière x ou y
jordan ces deux cahiers des deux bons il
aura du matos contre la dame mais bon au
moins on récupère quand même la dame sur
d'amd de on pourrait aussi jouer tous
rêvent de tête comme ses obligés de
revenir à 1 et on peut avoir l'idée de
faire cavalier g5 à un moment donné
aussi pourquoi pas donc quand même deux
trois idées
après c'est pas lourd cavaliers à cinq
je pense c'est assez bien joué
je vais mettre le cavalier angers 5
passes on s'y prend on reprendra de
l'adamant va jamais prendre du plomb qui
est des cinq c'est pas forcément très
bon ce que ça permet fou prend des
quatre éventuellement pour sortir la
dame mais c'était un peu débile comme
coup un peu beaucoup même
j'aurais mieux fait de faire dame ces
deux pros provoqué calais prend
reprendre et joue les caïds et de
récupérer la dame
donc il va faire froid ces sept on va
revenir avec le cavalier en fait ok
c'est pas la fin du monde perd juste un
temps par deux temps donc et tours b 8 a
par contre on l'a on est très content
d'avoir fait cette erreur
du coup erreur non réfuté devient bon
coup alors là l'expression à connaître
on s'est passé s'est passé mais mais ça
aurait pu ne pas passer dix heures à
faire flouer 6 comme ça sur fou prend
n'aura cavaliers prendre récupéra le le
fou g7 qui est toujours intéressant ça
lui évitera donnera des trucs avec food
et 4 dames des cats un certain moment
pour sortir la dame est maintenant non
affaire d'âme ses deux on va lui laisser
le cavale et on va faire qu'il y ait des
deux pour les enfermer saddam
on propose une non on va pas faire nul
allez on va jouer contre matt fr les
j'ai eu pas mal de défis de sa part l on
va lui faire du 4 à mathay faire
attaquer un membre actif de notre groupe
discorde
il est là à les maths
fessé 5 et on va l'embêter avec un grand
vide la leçon un petit peu parlé avec
lui sur le discorde et on va le prendre
par surprise quoi il ne connaissait pas
du coup on gagne le centre bon bah on a
dévié son pion prix d'un sacrifice avec
le fonds en d3 ya joué dessin va jouer
entre eux cinq ça va ressembler un peu à
une française mais il pourra plus me
faire ces cinq pour me gêner mon pions
ok il joue g6 on va développer
on va rock et rapidement on va aller on
va aller se venger sur ce puits en tout
de même ok j'ai envie de continuer un
peu dans l'esprit à fond va faire à
trois on va lui laisser prendre pour
reprendre avec le fou joué ses trois
pour bloquer ce qui rend le pion ils
dament le pion comme ça va faire c'est
trop on va blindés notre structure et
après on ira s'occuper des cases
noircies fait des cinq on fera au 5 et
son four est sera mal placé
avec ses 3 va complètement blindés la
structure de pions comme ça son cavalier
n'attaque rien c'est 5,5 et maintenant
il reste avec une française avec un
mauvais fou et son fiancé tout va pas
servir à grand chose on va aller on va
aller défoncer tout ça on va faire du
fou g5 d'amd de faux affichent 6 on va
on va on va monter à la volée ma tête il
doit tenter un truc avec apsys
d'ailleurs pourrait faire bouger 5 pour
essayer de tenter un e 5 à un moment
donné quand même ses cavaliers à 3
d'ailleurs pour faire cailler b5 et b6
installer la pieuvre ou alors faire qu'à
3 qui essaient deux cavaliers eu trois
cavaliers 4 est allé taper des cases
noires donc vous voyez c'est des plans
un peu long mais c'est des plans qui
peuvent qui peuvent rapporter gros et on
va mettre la tour en a trois pour
développe pour défendre le pion c'est
éventuellement ou la tour en c1 ça il va
ramener des pièces pour attaquer ici on
va défendre assez facilement et puis
nous pendant ce temps là on va ramener
ça là ça contrôleur un peu les cases
noires proches du roi de mathay faire
et on va continuer à mettre la pression
au petit matin faire ok donc pas mal
joué de la part de matt affaire il veut
se venger sur le pion les ramener son
cavalier en b 5
ça c'est plutôt bien fait mais on va lui
laisser aller on va être sympa on va lui
laisser un pion va même lui en laisser
deux et on va aller s'occuper de son roi
d'ailleurs il ya eu foule prend
cavaliers il faut prendre cavalière là
là quelle gaffe
en fait quand il a bougé le cavalier il
est c'est fou prend 1,7 mais bon c'est
encore petits soucis de concentration
mais on dit tout en contrôlant donc
c'est pas très grave on va lui mettre le
cavalant qu'est-ce qu'on lui mette en
effet six heures je n'ai envie de le
prendre là dans un premier temps ok
la mat comme très envie d'aller de maths
et installe un carré y ait ici j'ai
envie d'y aller à la très très brutal
j'ai envie d'y aller à la méga brutale
je sais pas si ça va suffire mais j'ai
envie d'être très brutal j'aurais
vraiment dû gagner la pizza qui comme
fait très brutal ici non mais on va
quand même garder le fou on sait jamais
quand en avoir besoin et on va essayer
d'aller finir le coup en sacrifiant de
partout mais on attribue aussi peut nous
coûter cher
en attendant aux échecs faire des gaffes
je vous ai dit un gars fnaut réfuté
devient bon coup et quand vous ratez des
pièces en un coup genre de choses ça
peut vous mettre en danger à tout niveau
je suis certainement fait fou des fins
b5 dam des deux tours c'est huit dames
f4 dame france et 3 j'ai bien envie de
faire juste tour c'est un rêve allait
finir le coup avec du damage quatre à
lyon va tenter le truc tour ses huit
voix retour à troyes il bouge le fou
damev 4 il attaque la tour d'un match 4
il pousse le pion cavaliers prend h5 qui
on prend dames prendront va finir le
courage cette voie on va faire ça
poursuit dans la sphère tour à 3 l'idée
tout à l'heure et puis on va les finir
le coup là bah ouais ça me paraît pas
mal parce qu'on a tellement de pièces
sur le roi et ça va pas pouvoir défendre
mais s'ils bougent le fou de cases
blanches en premier on mettra la tour
ans et ambre otages râle pion un pion ce
bar avec la dame
donc on va faire ce plan live où je l'aï
bouge le fonds fait d'un f4 fait
cavalier a et b 5e fait d'un match 4
on ramène les pièces on a quand même une
deux trois quatre cinq pièces et on peut
à un moment donné virtuellement faire du
c4 et touré tourage 3 voilà on a quand
même beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de matos
donc avoir amené salah vous fait
cavalier seitz peut pas vraiment venir
intervenir toute façon on fera d'un
match 4 pareil et cavaliers prend bekkat
alors là on s'en fout totalement au
virage 4 quand même menace mater on va
mater en force à saint calais pour
acheter un comprend h6 on prend ok donc
il va il va chercher le matos on lui
donne mais on ramène beaucoup de monde
sur son roi là on est tous à la la on
est les dragons de komodo sont de sortie
on souffle on est partout et on va le
finir allez on finit le coup les mecs
c'est une partie sympa et puis c'est une
attaque assez assez typique est donc là
on finit le coup avec le fameux fou
prend un fils et d'un match 6 pas assez
de pièces en défense pour mata faire
si ce prêt mouvement puisque il est
obligé de faire rage et huit
long-courriers donc en fait le problème
cette position bon après j'aurais dû
prendre la pièce mais c'est qu'en fait
même si je me suis semi raté le problème
c'est que je pense qu'il ya toujours été
perdant trop de pièces trop de pièces
sur le roi en fait ça fait trop de
pièces sur le roi même même s'il a une
qualité de plus le problème c'est que il
ya cinq pièces contre une en défense et
qui peut pas ramener deux joueurs en
défense puisqu'il ya là la structure de
pions qui bloque mais une partie
intéressante j'espère que ça t'aidera
mat ce que tu regardes en direct
j'espère que ça t'aidera que ça t'a fait
plaisir et que tu regarderas la partie
en replay tu pourras apprendre certaines
choses tu passes il est dans le chase
ailleurs peut-être sur le discorde
peut-être les tissus reddition alors
juste contre pierre de mauduit mais là
on a les dates du style pour le maroc
qui sont sortir le prochain stage au
maroc marc hongrie pro sen strauss ainsi
prochain stage du 9 au 16 et pour le
monde l'a juste sorti en interne il ya
déjà pas mal d'inscrits il ya déjà pas
mal d'inscrits donc ouais ça va aller
très très vite cette histoire de stage
allez on joue contre pierre maintenant
c'était dur ouais mais c'était
intéressant je pense je pense que
c'était d'autant plus intéressant pour
toi ça te permet de voir des plans et
d'apprendre certains trucs et devoirs
des schémas de maths
donc j'espère que ça va intéresser
tonton
alors on va on va y aller à la brutale
je sais que c'est pas très bon mais on
va essayer de brutaliser notre
adversaire 1975 on a lui laissé le fou
on va voir comment il se défend bon ceci
salle un tel jeu contre des joueurs
moins forcée de faire des plans un peu
marrant et puis de voir comment ils se
défendent la d'acné quai du maroc est on
était on est au maroc
l'an dernier pour le stage enfin l'an
dernier cette année il ya quelques mois
toutes ces pièces en attaque
l'adversaire a tout à fait comme une
dame qui défend pas et oui ça manquait
pièce est la maman pierre lebeau dit il
faut quand on donne des pièces un même
si ça fait un peu peur il vaut mieux les
prendre parce que quand tu les prends
pas en fait tu t'exposes encore plus aux
attaques adverses
on aurait dit si tu casse parfait pas
vraiment quand tu joues contre plus
faible que toi c'est toujours facile de
se passer pour kasparov
vous voyez bien quand je fais des titles
usées ou quand je mets des vidéos sur
match et de jouer contre des bons mecs
parce que c'est très facile de se faire
passer pour quelqu'un de fort quand tu
joues condé mec beaucoup plus faible
vous voyez sur ma chaîne youtube vous
voyez souvent voir des parties que je
perds j'en ai pas mal mais parra
notamment les title tuesday ou c'est pas
toujours c'est pas toujours rose mais
c'est aussi ça qui est intéressant c'est
pour mettre que des particules gagne
tout le temps pas vraiment bon mais là
c'est vrai que du coup comme il n'a pas
pris la pièce ça va nous permettre
d'encore plus sacrifiée j'ai envie de
dire et là on va m'en va y aller [ __ ]
en g3 qu'est-ce que vous aurez au maroc
ben là on va rien faire aux marocains
cette année mais l'année dernière on y
était salut bosse à l'usap sarah tonton
encore montaugé contrôle justin les gens
me défier puis je prends les défis petit
à petit mais reste plus beaucoup de
joueurs qui n'ont pas encore joué
on va reprendre
et on va mater merci pour cette partie
pierre allez on va prendre à lima da qui
parle souvent dans le tchat
il est souvent la dent les stream il
mérite
j'ai trois toujours envie oui j'ai trois
ce n'est pas le coup le plus le plus
fort alors allez on va faire un contre
gambie alpages et pas quand on s'appelle
albin je crois pas alpin être des alpes
très attention contre gambie alpestre
tient dégage
tiens parlons du maroc mmm gens ont
parlé du maroc et tout ça donc
gaujac me bonsoir 1 par le bon soir ce
soir il ya la pro d2 au sien grenade
bayonne grenoblois qui ont un peu de mal
tarifs mais durée et pas mal de monde
donc je sais pas si ça vous plaît relais
ce crime comme ça aussi n'oubliez pas le
25 décembre 20h45 date est prise tournoi
bitstream tournoi spécial noël
là on va directement le faire tourner en
club allez on peut pas faire on peut
faire tiens 25 décembre
je le fais en direct 20h45 on mais
quelle cadence les mecs spécial noël
je me sens est très heureux on fait quoi
on fait on fait du 3 + 2 ça va que nous
en pensée 3 plus de savoura bon en fait
juste roy + 2 ont fait on se fait c'est
trop long ce fait cinq ronds c'est quoi
on se fait cette ronde
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous les
faire combien de ronde france fait cette
ronde c'est noël on se fait plaise 20h45
ça me paraît être une bonne heure 3 plus
de cette ronde bitstream spécial noël
aura une offre on s'est fait un peu
beaucoup anatole 7 c'est bien l'échec
standard allait boom créé ça y est c'est
parti altran a spécial noël
dans les matches qui demande s'il peut
avoir un rematch bah ouais mais
abandonne un tonton je vais pas je vais
pas distribuer des points même si je
m'en fous des points des points internet
enfin je suis pas un distributeur de
points non plus quoi comment rejoindre
ce club info juste que tu trouves club
bitstream
alors je sais pas si on peut déjà
s'inscrire ou pas d'essayer si vous
voulez déjà essayé de vous inscrire
allez on lui doit une revanche est ok et
leurs prix mais bon si c'est revanche tu
vas 34 tu dégages cavalier a trois très
intéressant comme vous inventé par van
himst la guinée est fait je vous remets
ton qu'elle ait versé 2 peut-être dégage
donc il va être très très bien placés
l'un des quatre fûts je prends pour un
mètre carré en c2 nous sommes très
heureux et mon pions je protège aller là
qu'on va faire des 5e reprise prise
quel genre cavaliers cinq dames
d'écarter presse pourrait pas faire f 4
5 dam des quatre où j'essaie je pourrais
pas faire et quatre cavaliers f3 échec
après c'est à fond dans l'esprit car il
prend avec trois francs des quatre qui
prend 10 4 ou avec une dame de moins on
est à fond dans l'esprit à voir
c'est pour se marrer les malades qui a
clairement des problèmes de connexion
internet il en petit pls oui la dame qui
a rejoint hier il faut que tu rejoins
aimé ce que j'ai ce que tu connais
l'adresse de la chaîne la chaîne
bitstream
alors la question qu'est une quand est
ce qu'on aura la chance de connaître les
complots de la prod chassery ben en fait
il manque qu'un joueur qui n'est pas
officialisé ou plutôt une joueuse et
donc quand on aura officialisé cette
joueuse je pense au début de l'année on
parlera un peu de l'approché sling mais
j'ai déjà annoncé sur le discorde notre
première recrue d'emprunt recrues qui
est maxime lagarde très bonnes recrues
on est très très heureux de cette recrue
très très très très heureux même sommes
plus heureux que jamais heureux comme
jamais complètement heureux comme la
migraine talent qui est pas content à
une note speak valley fringe very well
as will stop aux français très important
d'apprendre le français les enfants très
importants comme l'anglais attention non
mais l'anglais sans déconner les mecs
c'est enfin parler anglais c'est quand
même un minimum fâché qu'il ya des
enfants qui regardent les mecs ayez des
bonnes notes en anglais franchement déjà
rien que si tu regarde des séries
joaillier nature garde les selles en
quelle langue tu regardes en anglais
sous-titré ce titre en quelle langue
mais quand tu sautes x-tu ce titre quoi
as tu auras anglais sous titres anglais
dit aux enfants c'est important
d'apprendre l'anglais
parce qu'après il regarde est ce que tu
vois qu'ils regardent la vidéo ils se
disent de video is in french nerfs sur
qui a eu cinq iliad à me donnant les
mecs auquel j'avais pas pensé beaucoup
plus fort que dame des quatre comme ça
je force plus ou moins dame là et puis
je fus cole peut-être un petit des six
au passage si proche le clou 6 vient
aussi sa ex adam bomb apoel capter des
quatre noms mais aucun lieu 5 je fais
dans me2 sur youtube et which we may
noria pas de travail
natal lui qu'il est rien et gagner moi
aussi j'suis trilingue
on représente gros s'il est ici un mail
anglais pas d'excusés pas un poème de
pratiques tu regardes les films en
anglais tu fais de l'anglais de partout
tout le temps du refus d'harmos est des
six états et des trois échecs juste pour
montrer un truc que je pense au début dé
si je le sens c'est très malin il ya
cavaliers detroit échec qui joue sur le
clouage jolie roi bouge dame prend 1,2
faut prendre 2 qui est français un tour
prend c'est un fou prend des six études
et garage faut faire attention à l'est
on va le contre rafael arabia qui
devient les argentinas si lionel messi
la pulga
mais je parle le russe très attention
allez comme il argentins ont valu faire
de la samba rouaix tron va être des poux
mas quoi faire c'est si ceci je ne
prends pas ton pions ça ne m'intéresse
pas à phu d2 tient bon allez on continue
dans l'esprit est même si on devrait
probablement récupérer durant surtout si
c'est pour jouer 6 mais bon on va on va
voir pendant combien de temps
résiste-t-il quoi résister précis
fiables à l'espagnol à bâle espagnol
clark et si et si et si et le cavalero
cabaret locon commères et des think when
we bienne s'est hissée ici alors fou g4
hockey d'ailleurs exigé appris le
français en regardant bitstream lui est
très heureux à y regarder il n'ya pas de
chaîne aussi bien en anglais c'est la
meilleure chaîne d'échec
comment quand on voit comment faire le
mec a carrément appris le français
j'en pense que tu parle espagnol
maintenant son niveau en espagnol et en
très intéressant battu par nuit
espagnole que moi je pense non espagnol
je suis je suis complètement nul nantes
qu'est ce que tu regardes comme série
télé les gens sont beaucoup plus
intéressés partez vous je pense qu'ils
ont compris que moi je faisais de la
merde mais bon game of thrones tu
regardes quoi d'autre walking dead thème
pas trop du lycée avec damien suits
thème bien ouais t'as mis au monde
t'aime bien quoi d'autre
black mirror que tu aimes bien réussi
moi j'aime bien réussi black mirror
c'est pas mal on regarde quoi d'autre
strangers singstar pas trop et n'ai pas
regardé jusqu'au bout quand même mais ça
n'a pas trop plu non mais tu regardes tu
regardais big bang theory aussi ça tu
aimais bien ça
mais à d'autres je regardais girl's
aussi scrubs of white stripes scrubs il
est vraiment pas mal
bon alors on attend qu est ce qui se
passe dans les scop c'était vrai que
c'est vrai que c'est sympa mais aussi
faut dire qu'il était très bien doubler
en russe à scrubs attend de seconde
[Musique]
moi j'ai envie de prendre là c'est un
peu de la merde
ah ouais tout à fait ouais je parle de
partout partout où elle va faire b 6 à 5
j'en peux jouer comme une merde mais
vous diront c'est pas trop aidé avec
l'ouverture bien vite chassée se fout en
fait dont elle est double et là bas et
puis
une tour ans et 8 ok on est pas si bien
bien accueilli 6,6 aïe aïe aïe
ouais ou ça on n'aura pas super bien
joué cette partie aurait pu gagner à
l'été un chef chef 30,54 aller 2003 les
aurès mettre en danger on va se battre
on va lui faire une robe est il prêt
quoi est ce qui la rocqué a vendu et la
partie fait de la pub pour le discorde
mais le lien pour le discours d'un ton
qui une fois de chasse bras gagnant dès
2010 en leur donnant sa dame des débuts
ouais mais probablement pas dès 2002
check point comme ses plus forts 2002
check point comme quand même phrase de
john john très mécontent que je te parle
très mécontents et dit oui concentre toi
pour jouer et non mais non si j'arrive à
gagner en parlant en même temps je fais
ce que je veux quoi ayant jugé même le
droit de perdre personne ne m'oblige à
gagnes tu penses qu'ils sont jaloux
ouais possible possible c'est possible
alors allez on fait on se fait notre
attaque spike
alors attends attends attends attends
maintenant on a un pion à un échange à
un pion bon on va prendre on va prendre
à faire cavalier f3 va faire du près
move
bien vite faire quel est des deux baies
5 à 4 donc il mêle foule a pas mal joué
mais de cavaye en d4
alors ce que ça donne on est d'encaisser
sa sueur foule a en fait eu quatre
peut-être fou mais ici je sais pas
kiev au v6 pas mal joué alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait si on enlève le cavalier va
venir prendre le truc si on prend là il
prend là on fait des six il bouge on
prend on prend on prend on fait grand
roque
ouais on va prendre l'a6 et français ok
on va prendre là on va prendre là
ça a une gueule correct pour le moment
c'est tout pour le moment
fred est petit dédé voit quand même la
chose ça va faire des imitations
c'est tout pour le moment maintenant on
a peur de fou on est très heureux je
viens d imitation mais non je pensais
minimisation de merde actions afin de
faire mais ok on va faire rock une
qualif cinq semi chiant fut f4 et prend
hk tour d un j'arrive pas calculer mais
bon peut-être cavaliers l'a peut-être on
fait tourner et indirects en fait
pendant à faire du tour d un direct de
façon sans celui fou de mettre une tour
où l'eau tu vas pas là qu'elle est mieux
placé au quai foule on va faire ça
cavaliers sans affaire fouet 4 et on va
essayer de tout court il en veut faire
[ __ ] ans et si c'est tout reprend
voilà on joue sur les multis clouage
alpha 0 dans ta gueule quoi tu coût est
partout
[Musique]
ok bon là il doit y avoir un gain c'est
sûr alors sur cavaliers prend ok mais si
je fais foot france et six du coup il
doit faire roi prend j'arrive pas
calculer c'est honteux dont quelques uns
mais les prix eux cinq prises et tour
c'est un rêve qu atos et sis échec ça
attendez c'est toi seul doit gagner on
va faire qu'elle prend là il va prendre
du fou et on va faire tour c'est un
comme ça sur france et 4 soup rang avec
un drap vert tout reprend ses 6 et le
roi m'a l'air quand même ultra faible
même souvent je vois pas de match ce qui
est assez embêtant ce que ce retour 17
la tour en échec mais inquiet on peut
quand même amené là on va faire tour 17
quand même ça une bonne gueule un fou
prend au tourcoing f7 et à une très
bonne comme si ça allait mais tour c'est
8 on va faire prise tourcoing f7 est fou
prend la 8 ok mais là dessus on va
prendre là ça s'est traduit la
tranquille à traîne qui l'attend
franprix h6 prise prise fukatsu prend h7
foot est roi mais ça tombe pas tonton
way grauby fier gros me fier allez on a
un gros but fier on va jouer maintenant
contre pirlouit père louis belge s était
pas mal joué tu as 30 52 s est bien
battu contre la grave il aura bien
résisté mais il s'est quand même fait
grauby fier
il est très content et vous allez hop
c'est cinq essais de s'en prendre aux
pions centre au t6 va faire froid s'ils
ont affaire à six baies 5 essayer de
faire b4 salavat nous attaquez pas mal
fait de la femme de pierre louis qui a
raison d'attaquer à fond tu faisais pas
des trucs que je joue donc je suis pas
j'ai pas forcément brillant je suis pas
brillant comme dany
donc pas des positions que je joue bien
en plus vraiment style fusion je
comprends vraiment très bien en fait
bloqué quand même ça a passé c'est le
passé c'est pousser pendant ce moment
peut-être faire d'un v6 d'un v4 comme ça
attaqué comme çà latéralement sera pas
mal ça c'est pas une mauvaise idée la
graine d'avoir pour une fois
une ivg cas tu peux toujours prendre non
ça m'a l'air d'aller ça n'allait pas
trop mal finalement
mais aucun l'âme des quatre taxes ou 17
b 5
on a tenté un truc comme ça ça se
construit ça se construit on est pas mal
on est pas mal des tentes ou lost aunès
elle est en espagnol automatiquement
totaux nes mais ok ça va aller je vois
qu'il ya de trous ça ici dans le chatt
d'ailleurs invité de marque
attention les mecs - fo 17 ça va ça va
faire mal on va taper le pion puis on a
cadré des gens masqués les trois ou
quatre ans
du coup on est pas mal on est pas mal
ouais lui va bien il se bat bien il va
bien mais là c'est ok mais non tu
comprends ce pion puisqu'ils horrible
c'est qu'on menace il a au passage
maintenant tu arraches 4 faible est sûre
j'ai trop on en profitera pour lui
claque un petit fouet la du coup il ya
ce pion qui tombe de base qui paraissait
bon squash 4 est finalement peut-être
pas si mauvais mais on va revenir ans
d'écart avec lala dames lave sur la
quatrième elle fait feu de tout bois
et c'est vrai que ça coûte d'am dam des
six dames b4 bah ouais bon si on veut
faire un truc micro pédagogique parce
que mon à ses fins et de la pédagogie de
merde en fait mais faut le savoir
clairement
enfin on fait pas de pédagogie qu'entre
des blitz en direct mais bon j'en
profite après pour montrer ce petit plan
dam des six dames b4 je sais les
pressions joue pas très bien mais ça
peut être pas mal pour mettre la
pression sur / 4 / a4 est un jour on a
dû dam des cas du fou 17 du prises on
aide un peu bessin donc c'était un petit
plan sympa touche alors à jouer contre
gauthier 84 je suis un de 8 4 cantons si
ici et on va lui faire f cartwright
change un peu les cours ont fait le truc
différentes partout boom de trousses a
ici qui dit bonjour
donc il fait des cinq cavaliers f3
développons nous car elle et ses six
baies 3 m le fou sur la grande diagonale
qu'est donc là on va pas se laisser
prendre le truc
m e 5 tue pas c'est une bonne idée qu'a
eue saint georges le ca tempo che a pu
faire 3 pour protéger le cavale pour pas
me faire doubler les pions il ne reste
pas il ne reste pas méga de temps il
nous reste à tien qu'il prendrait quatre
buts damas quatre élèves de la double
attaque ne fonctionne pas fond de court
le 3 ça y est tout est défendu
alors maintenant que tout est défendu on
va passer au plan b
l'attak chasser la dame m lequel on sait
trois semi gaffe quand même parce que je
veux faire et c'est et qui prend là je m
lecavalier en le 4 en plus de protéger
par l'autre on va mettre le fou en b 5
jamais méga conforté dans ses positions
et des pièces pas très bien placé comme
ça allez va faire d'alger 4 comme ça sur
f5 d'un projet cet échange et les dames
jamais une très bonne idée mais ff5 que
j'avais raté mais c'est pas grave qui
accueille 35 comprend le cac et prend
c'est ici sur a6 encore est fou à 4 on a
un peu de chance un peu de chance la
tactique tourner dans notre sens puis on
prend quatre ans et six à 6 x 4 et peut
jamais prendre à cause de fou prend
hélas pas b5 ce que le fou gêne ça passe
juste ça passe juste
on n'est pas du tout vu un c'est
complètement de la merde mais on on l'a
vu on est on est juste mais on l'a vu au
dernier moment alors à faire acquérir
les cinq du coût du coup ci fait grand
recueil qui arrive en f 7
quelle horreur je vais peut-être faire
cavalier si ce n'est pas le roi n'a plus
de cas ça me fait marrer
bon mais juste à ma mieux ça me ça
m'amuse un petit peu à prendre
il prend on va mettre le four à trois
pas bouger les cavaliers pour le monde
va rester on va rester en mode tu ne
bouge pas et que je suis à l'étranger
7,3 et philippe rouah f5
ok mais là je peux prendre ici il est
obligé de partir par là comme ça je peux
faire cavalier avec cet échec et lui
prendre la tour assez horrible il a
tellement peu de cases avec son roi le
pauvre gauthier en quelle tristesse ok
alors qu'ils attendaient les gens qui
n'ont pas à jouer on à louches 6
britannien à désole un fourré pas tous
passer mais je fais ce que je peux je
fais ce que je peux
c'est d'avoir le maximum de gens
possible qui joue contre moi alors on
peut pas prendre tout le monde on va
retomber dans l'île sicilienne comme ça
ça marrant on retrouvait dans le cas de
ces cinq cavaliers f3e six cavaliers ces
trois cas f6 des quatre hockey et là on
va re transposer je pense dans un autre
truc qui va recevoir une espèce de
française variantes des changes
je vais réussir à coup les fulbé cinq
échecs rock qui prend
dans quel sens on fait ça que j'ai envie
de prendre s'y prend je fais ckt sur
damour catéchètes je fais fouet 3 et
après geoffrey food et 4 ok il prend
comme ça je fumais 5 quand même je vais
tout est changé je veux contre un pion
isolé et je vais roquet est en fait je
vais essayer de faire tour un pion prend
pied sur fouet cette je vais prendre
ok il vient là pas idiot parce que si je
prends il fait foot france et 5 il
économise un temps du coup je mets quand
même la tour e 1
ce sera un coup utile quand il bouge le
fou je vais prendre ce que je l'achète
cavalli g5 maintenant à voir donc ils
couvrent et je prends comme ça quand il
prend j'aurais peut-être carélie g5
après quand même avoir avoir manqué
dame-là la rigueur à 4 pas sûr que ce
soit le bon coup
pas idiot ça lui permet youpi joue pas
mal à ces quelques coups comme ça si je
prends quand il prend et menacera hebdo
pas idiot c'est pas bête du tout d'avoir
chaud comme ça
à
trois grands que ça me paraît quand même
un peu vain vu que j'ai déjà poussé à 4
en plus c'est que j'ai qui l'a poussé
ses pions devant son roi je vois pas du
tout comme en europe de ce côté là moi
je vais reculer le fou et je vais
préparer prises et puis il fallait tout
pousser quoi l'âge quand même beaucoup
plus frais à l'attaqué lui de ce côté là
qu'il ne l'est de l'autre côté ils
échangent un donc le jeu est très ouvert
de l'endroit noire paraît pas pas
folichon folichon et ont passé un petit
à 5com sans gagner un tempo sur la dame
et on va prendre à faire ces trois
peut-être
sur un truc avec ses trois sur des cas
de fer b4 quand même et pourra jamais
prendre ces trois points sur à tour ses
seins et de façon si jamais il fait roi
des huit je veux faire b 4 dames france
et 3b 5 s'il ferait van bay 5 comme ça
je voulais tout les colonnes de vol
devant le roi et je vais aller mater en
force la c3 bekkat là c'est assez fort
fin c'est assez violent surtout b4
d'apprendre enfin même s'il fait des
cadres des cats il peut pas faire décès
à cause de baisser il donne la tour en
d1 en fait je gagne une tour de france
et 3 il peut pas non plus pas faire
grand chose en fait
ok il peut reculer la dame et là j'ai
hésité mais j'ai peut-être faire ces
quatre mêmes comme ça après j'avance
avec b5 salage en voyage envoie du lourd
b6 soit qu'ils avaient sapé si c'est
suicidaire peut-être que faire dame c5
et c'était encore chaud
cette dame c'est 5 c'était pas mal joué
j'ai pas joué de manière extraordinaire
une nouvelle fois mais ça suffit
surtout la met juste pour montrer ses
cadres des quatre
quand j'ai fait ça peut-être la dame c5
pas mal joué
puis on prend prises et ça permet de
bloquer le pion ces branchements
j'aurais fait tour b 1 mais peut-être
c'est un truc avec détroit et et jouer
sur le pion même si après 2003 tout ça
ça doit être difficile puisque je menace
mater tous mais il aurait pu essayer un
truc comme ça peut-être plus résistants
allez on va prendre un dernier
et qui n'a pas joué on va prendre
on va reprendre un joueur étranger on va
prendre
wiseman que j'ai pu voir dans le tchat
on va voir si on finit vite on aura le
temps de reprendre 1 si on finit vite on
aura le temps de reprendre un adversaire
on va essayer de le finir vite
fou j'ai cadré c'est avec grand roque a
une nouvelle fois va faire russie si
fâcheux croix en fer h5 pressé il ya là
la brutale et si on finit avant 21h30 on
en refait une derrière c'est possible
c'est possible alors baissé de
brutaliser total ramené la dame en a
chaque à l'e-book match 5 vous vient
prendre bien prendre le fou allez viens
d'un match 5 et on va mater en force
on peut le faire on peut le faire sur kg
sans la faire flasher deux échecs safway
catéchèse kheddam pranger 5 est vrai
donc ok c'est exactement le scénario et
chaque échec et on gratte ça le fond f4
il a il a couvert et sur fou prend va
venir prendre la g3 pour couvrir d'un
match 6 on va les mater en h2 je pense
qu'on va y arriver on aura une autre
partie sinon menace fourrage de roy
issifou g iii roi ici tourache un roi
prend d'un match qu'à 3g un damage de
maths
donc on a aussi une menace de maths
qu'on va appliquer tout de suite
j'espère que vous avez suivi mais là
savaient tout en promouvant
damages 4 et damages de le petit match
qui fait plaise avec le sacrifice de
tours en h1 qui va nous donner une
dernière partie qui a une dernière une
dernière partie et on va apprendre à les
user name aller si on la finit en moins
de deux minutes
allez on va essayer de faire un de près
move un max pour histoire une der des
ders aller ont réussi avant la der des
ders jeu trop vite aussi de patrons se
met en danger mais ok on va tenter le
max on va tenter le max je crois achats
juge ou pas du tout comme ça en plus
mais ok nous tentons nous tentons
l'essai de gagner vite donc on va
renvoyer du monde
vous voyez la dame en éclaireuse peut
faire plein de rêves 5-1 clairement et
s'y prend va les prendre et ramener le
cahier angers saint cloud en c4 je sais
par veut mater à la violente
il nous reste deux minutes
il nous reste figurait une 40 si on veut
réussir à passer ça va être chaud on va
faire un 4 ça mange pas de pain prendre
un peu d espace
jean paquet les idées sur à 5 ans fait
qu'apparemment il en a pas pas prendre
prendre tous ces 4,5 on vas vis et pas
de peau de banane avec le cavalier qui
bouge parce qu'il peut pas mettre en
échec en deux coups et il est en
diagonale par rapport à la dame dont il
peut pas protéger et maintenant on va
aller tenter le tour h3 et à les mater à
la violente
allez les mecs nous sommes des brutes à
l'ailé brut mon quartier de matos pour
le matin et à me prend roi prendre
courage trois cavalières quatre tours hk
3g machin il se sauve
y'a pas de maths rapide on va prendre là
une fois mettre le fond ou trois moments
n'ya pas b5 à cause de fou prend comment
ce qu'on disait ses clous et il nous
reste plus de temps là malheureusement
15 secondes on réussira pas à voir une
autre partie et on n'a plus de plan de
maths et bien ça va finir là-dessus ça
va finir sur cette partie ok il se bat
bien l'adversaire ont pas réussi à les
mater on aura vraiment tenter le passage
en force
ça ne sera pas passé pour qu'on reste
damage sept matches il doit faire
acheter soit affaire qui prend des cinq
dames prend des 5 et d'un projet 6
on sera un tout petit peu en retard
on se rend tout qui porte à rien ce sera
peut-être pour la semaine prochaine si
on fait des parties qui va prendre sa
juste ce qui est pratique c'est que la
dame mon cas ou d'échangé de aussi sur
un truc comme tour des huit je vais
justement vous parlez de ça jordan
surprise en g2
en fait j'aurais pu avoir un truc
marrant c'est un match peut pas vous
montrer
mais imaginez d'un projet deux tours
projet de tour d un match ça aurait pu
être joli et là-dessus bas c'est nous
qui allons mater viatour praxis je vous
montrerai en finissant puis on prend et
fouet f6 maths mais là bas il y aurait
pu avoir un truc assez joli ouais donc
dame pranger 2 juste que vous voyez bien
bon là je fais d'un projet de laisser
gagner mais si je fais tout reprend j'ai
deux tours d un math faut le voir
petites tactiques sympa pour pour
terminer ce stream et et voilà j'espère
que j'espère que ça vous aura plu
j'espère que ça vous aura plu vous aurez
bien amusé à jouer contre moi si
celui-ci vous qui fait sa ba n'hésitez
pas à l'écrire sur le sur le discorde
comme ça je peux le lire je peux lire
après et voilà merci tout le monde
d'avoir suivi le stream n'oubliez pas
qu'on aura le tournoi ensemble 25
décembre à 20h45
je sais pas si on sait déjà inscrits ou
pas hachey déception sera ouverte ou pas
tournoi up coming sur les spéciales n'en
reçoit nouveau à ward enfin débutera le
laboratoire vous inscrire et et voilà
bonne soirée tout le monde
ciao pouces bleus toujours partout tout
le temps